what is a multiverse how does it work
and why does it matter more importantly
what does it mean for the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe based on what
we've seen so far and what's coming
here's our best shot at explaining the
MCU multiverse listen carefully to the
conversation between the ancient one and
Bruce Banner in Avengers endgame and it
tells you just about everything you need
to know about how the MCU multiverse
works the ancient one doesn't want to
give Banner the time stone because she
fears doing so will create an alternate
timeline there would then be a timeline
in which the time stone left her care
during the Battle of New York and so
would never be in kamar Taaj for Steven
strange to use in Doctor Strange there
would also still be yet another timeline
where the time stone never left her care
and events unfolded as we already know
them simply put you can't change the
past if you travel to the past that past
becomes your future and your former
present becomes the past which can't now
be changed by your new future if you try
to change the past you create a paradox
for example if you go back in time and
stop your parents from ever meeting then
how do you exist and if you don't exist
how do you go back in time to stop your
parents from meeting you can't go on
like that forever
the universe solves this paradox by
creating an alternate timeline something
the Avengers have to deal with as part
of their journey to collect the Infinity
stones during the lead-up to 2019
spider-man far from home there was a lot
of conversation about whether the film
confirmed the existence of an MCU
multiverse in the trailer we learned
that Quentin Beck claims to be from an
alternate universe where his world was
destroyed he was supposedly in the prime
MCU timeline doing what he could to stop
the same thing from happening of course
it turns out Quentin Beck was lying
about almost everything he wasn't from
another universe and neither were the
elemental creatures he was fighting in
fact the elementals weren't even the
elementals they were mysterious
illusions created by a swarm of drones
and Holograms but it's important to
remember that the fact that Mysterio
wound up not
being from another universe doesn't
disprove the existence of the MC use
multiverse from his earliest comic book
appearances Mysterio set himself up as a
super villainous con man and liar but
that doesn't mean he's wrong
in fact Mysterio himself has already had
some real multiverse adventures in the
pages of Marvel Comics the weirdest part
of the back and forth about whether
Mysterio's cover story confirmed the
existence of an MCU multiverse was the
fact that the conversation was going on
at all
three years before far from homes
release the MCU multiverse was confirmed
without Quentin Beck's help in 2016 s
Doctor Strange the ancient one confirms
the existence of a multiverse within the
MCU when she sent Stephen strange on his
memorable trip through that multiverse
as the bedraggled strange floats through
the cosmos the ancient one provides a
narration for his trippy journey among
other things she tells strange so there
you have it regardless of the home
address of Quentin Beck the MCU has a
multiverse and its existence was
confirmed long before far from home
though it's understandable why this was
forgotten or ignored far from home was
preceded by endgame the first MCU film
to really have anything significant to
do with time travel and alternate
timelines that's probably why it was
closer to the forefront of everyone's
minds than it might have been while
watching Doctor Strange in 2016 Steve
Rogers decision to remain in the past at
the end of Avengers endgame is a perfect
example of how the MCU multiverse works
when asked about caps final fate endgame
co-director Joe Russo confirmed that
when he stays in the past and marries
Peggy Carter the life Steve lives occurs
in an alternate timeline then at some
point Steve somehow returns to the prime
MCU timeline to give his shield to Sam
Wilson one of the big questions on fans
Minds is if cap really did accomplish
his mission Steve's job was to return
all the stones at the exact moments they
were taken from the various times
thereby stopping alternate timeline
from being created but first of all we
never see steve's quest so we don't know
if things worked as planned
second there's a question of whether
banners theory around bringing the
stones back is sound in the first place
banner tells the ancient one that
bringing the stones back to the precise
moments when they're taken and returning
them will stop the timelines from
splitting but would it or is it possible
it would make things worse for example
banner takes the time stone as soon as
he takes the stone an alternate timeline
has been created with bringing the stone
back erase the second timeline or would
it create a third this is why we can
only hope time machines remain in the
realm of fiction time travel somewhere
out there in the multiverse Loki is
alive and the reason he is alive is not
only what allows for his upcoming Disney
Plus miniseries but it also possibly
complicates things with MC use
multiverse even more an endgame
Loki gets his hands on the tesseract
while Thor is trying to resuscitate Tony
Stark once he does it disappears in a
blue cloud a new timeline has been
created one in which Loki was never
brought to Asgard to face Odin's justice
after the Battle of New York presumably
we'll be finding out what happens to
that Loki in his upcoming mini-series
whether banners theory on how to unsplit
her the timeline is correct when it
comes to this specific alternate
timeline it doesn't matter
remember Loki's escape prevents Steve
and Tony from getting the tesseract
forcing them to go back to the 70s and
get it from shield when cap goes back in
time to return the stones at the end of
endgame he only has one tesseract to
return presumably he's going to return
it to the 70s but that means everything
that happens in stark tower in 2012 all
still happened that timeline still
exists and it's going to be Loki's
playground there's one more alternate
timeline that couldn't have been erased
by caps journey to the past the timeline
in which the 2014 Thanos and his forces
jump forward to 2023 an assault Avengers
compound when Thanos captures nebula
from 2023 they reverse-engineer her Pym
particles
replace her with 2014 nebula what does
that all mean there now exists a time
line in the MCU where Thanos and all his
forces disappear in 2014
never to return as soon as the
respective interstellar empires of that
time line realized he's gone they'll
probably have one huge multi planet
party that lasts a few decades returning
the soul stone to Vermeer can't alter
thanassis disappearance it can only
create more divergent timelines in a way
you could argue Tony Stark does double
duty when he snaps away the mad Titan at
the end of endgame he wipes out Thanos
from not just one but two universes we
don't know a lot yet about 2020 ones
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness but just from the name it seems
likely we're going to be learning more
about the MC use multiverse in the
Doctor Strange sequel if any hero is
equipped to explore the multiverse its
Doctor Strange this first film
introduces the multiverse and it's that
multiverse that strange uses the time
stone to explore in 2018 Avengers
infinity war it's possible the events of
endgame are the key to whatever is going
wrong in the upcoming sequel endgame is
the only time we've seen any kind of
significant time travel in the MCU the
very phrase multiverse of madness
suggests something has gone wrong with
the multiverse and if that's the case
then all the time hopping the heroes and
villains of endgame did could be the
reason another big hint is the upcoming
Disney Plus miniseries Wanda vision we
don't know much more about the series
than we do about the Doctor Strange
sequel but what we do know is intriguing
star Elizabeth Olsen has said at least
part of the series will have a 1950
setting which hints pretty strongly at a
multiverse connection at the same time
we heard about stories like Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness we
learned we were going to be meeting the
Mighty Thor aka Jane Foster in the
fourth entry of the Thor franchise Thor
love and thunder what does this have to
do with the multiverse well all that
time hopping an endgame may give us the
most obvious answer to the question of
how Jane gets all mighty Steve Rogers
has Mjolnir with him when he goes back
in time at the end
and game but it isn't with him when he
returns as an elderly man presumably
Steve would have returned the hammer to
Asgard circa 2013 when he returned the
ether if so then that might be the
answer for the sake of argument assumed
that when Steve arrives in 2013 Asgard
he doesn't grab the first Asgardian he
sees and say hey I'm a time traveler can
you tell me where Thor is assume cap
simply leaves the hammer somewhere
knowing it will go to Thor as soon as
the Thunder God summons it and then
continues on his journey then assume
Jane Foster comes upon the hammer
wherever Steve happens to leave it kind
of curiosity if you found yourself alone
with the hammer of Thor wouldn't you
give it a shot
one possibility that's loomed since
before Disney's acquisition of Fox is
that Marvel characters whose film rights
are still held by other Studios might be
narrative Lee connected to the MCU
through the multiverse when rumors
swirled that venom might be showing up
in spider-man far from home the
multiverse was an explanation some fans
clung to while there's been no
indication that Marvel Studios plans to
use the multiverse in this way it's not
out of the question with the Fantastic
Four x-men and Deadpool
all under the Disney umbrella it could
be there are elements of their
respective Fox films that Marvel likes
if so one way to keep them whole would
be to simply say the previous movies
took place in an alternate timeline the
same possibility exists with venom as
well as the other Marvel property Sony
is either actively adapting or planning
to adapt like Morbius Kraven the hunter
and silver sable this is an idea
Marvel's already used though it was
Marvel Comics instead of Marvel Studios
in the 2014 comics event spider-verse
versions of spider-man in other media
were considered to be alternate universe
spider-man the spider-man from the 80s
spider-man and his amazing friends
cartoon from the newspaper strip and
even from old hostess ads Marvel's
comics used to carry were all considered
genuine spider-man from other universes
in the sequel 2018 s spider get in the
spider-man of that year's PlayStation 4
spider-man video game was one of the
comics hero
thanos brutally murders loci in the
opening scene of 2018 Avengers infinity
war and later in the same film he hurls
his adoptive daughter Gamora to her
death on Vermeer yet both Loki and
Gamora show up in the 2019 follow up
Avengers endgame and we'll be seeing
both of them again Loki will enjoy his
own solo miniseries on Disney Plus while
Kimora will almost definitely be back
for the upcoming guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 both characters survive as part of
alternate realities even if Captain
America returned all the Infinity stones
exactly where they were meant to be
Loki's escaped in New York City and
Thanos his journey to the future each
creates splintered timelines that can't
be undone by Steve Rogers the MCU
multiverse provides a resurrection easy
button for Marvel Studios storytellers
want to bring back Odin the Warriors 3
and all the others guardians they must
exist in an alternate timeline want to
reunite Wanda Maximoff with her
speedster brother who dies in age of
Ultron there must be a timeline where
Ultron didn't kill him that doesn't just
go for the good guys either with the
multiverse more prominent in the MCS
narrative we could see the return of any
villain as far back as Jeff Bridges
Obadiah Stane check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Marvel movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]